good to see you all happy Monday hope
you're doing well we're doing well here
we're working from home like so many
millions of others across America and
while we're doing that guys we're taking
a look at some of the stories we think
you'll be talking about today including
this Jay crew has just announced its
filing for bankruptcy protection it's
the first national retailer to take this
action since the pandemic forced the
company to temporarily close all of its
j.crew and Madewell stores the company
sales had slipped in recent years and it
is nearly 2 billion dollars in debt the
retailer says it expects to stay in
business and emerge from bankruptcy as a
profitable company Anthony you'll
remember back in 2017 they just barely
escaped declaring for bankruptcy back
then yeah this is this is a rough time
for any company that was was struggling
to begin with and there one of those
there are rumors Vlad also of course
reports the Neiman Marcus and JCPenney
are also on the edge hopefully that
won't happen but you know in the in the
case of j.crew 492 stores all closed
through this and some of them will it
turns out will probably be permanently
closed so that's too bad